this guy's still walking they had to
following commands for taser I think
that's about to happen looks like a bad
do too to be on something which way are
they facing
please facing west bow I need to get
this uh eastbound flows down if they
could gonna be able to let anybody
there are instances on battlefields of
gruesome gerson Wars where people have
their hands up and they live and those
around battlefields and we're talking
about freeways I think now when I hear
the word police
I feel very differently than I did when
I was younger I think growing up clearly
as a white woman police was mostly a
positive word to me it was people who
kept me safe it was people who were in
my family I think as someone who has
never had any issues with a lot never
occurred to me that I'd have any sort of
negative interaction with police so the
word police and the concept growing up
was a very positive helpful word that I
felt fine about as I've grown up and as
I've become more aware of the climate
that we're living in the meaning in the
tone of that word has changed completely
police are doing some things that makes
me feel that I don't know if they're who
I would call for safety it's just
upsetting that in a law enforcement
profession having the wrong intentions
or thinking too quickly about something
could result in the loss of a life as a
black man the question has become will
the world allow me to live it's so
unfortunate and so
sad to think that we live in the
greatest country in the world and the
people who are here to protect that make
us feel unprotected it's interesting
because it's like I feel like every
single time a black person is killed we
always say like this one is different
and it's not because you can have your
hands up you can be reading a book in
your car you can be disabled
you're just automatically a threat it's
not new it's just we're being killed in
a different way cut the last year maybe
one time it's an accident maybe one time
it's an isolated incident and when it's
this many times like how many times have
we had to watch videos of this one of
the first things that cops to do is
admit that we are all born with a racial
bias I think it is so built into our
society and our culture and our media
and the lessons that we learn as
children that I think people rely on
that thing if you're a police officer
and you're trying to side constantly
who's good who's bad who's a threat
who's not the second there's a doubt all
of these subconscious biases and
opinions and beliefs that we've been
taught since childhood in this country
come up and they think it seems likely
that person will have a gun it seems
likely that person's gonna hurt me I
mean you look from a helicopter and you
say that's one bad dude how do you know
you only know because you've been raised
in this country where you are being
subconsciously told all the time that
guys who look like that are bad dudes I
definitely think that some people go
into the police force with the best of
intentions and I know some people that
have and they're good people but
ultimately it's to keep the system in
place and the system that currently
exists
hurts minorities it does not stand up
for everyone it is based purely on
inequality and injustice it should be
that we are all the same that we are all
brothers and sisters but this world
thinks otherwise I think we got here
because of 300 years or more of slavery
I think we got here because the idea of
black people being humans is less than a
century old I think that we got here
because after MLK made I have a dream
speech people thought that it was over
if that it was done that everything was
finished and I think we continue to
operate under the guise that we live in
a post-racial America unless we stop
talking about race and how we can
progress it I am NOT hopeful at all I've
lost hope I don't think that anything is
gonna change
and that's scary
[Music]
because I want to have kids and I want
to have a husband and I want to have a
life and I want to live my life
unapologetically and I want other I want
my friends to be able to live their
lives unapologetically and that's I
don't see that happening without always
being fearful like without always
thinking twice about everything that we
do like I can't even Drive down the
street without being like are there any
cops like what's gonna happen or like
having a cop car drive behind me that is
the scariest thing for me right now like
and I shouldn't have to be scared of
that like I shouldn't have like it's
just a cop car behind me like that makes
me scared I don't I don't have any hope
right now even for myself I have
witnessed all these terrible things that
have been going on just like everyone
else but with this last one it just felt
a little different for me and I know
that everyone needs to feel that because
it's not okay i 100% believe that this
country is afraid of black men because
this country has been taught that black
men are inherently monsters in every
video we seen of these police shooting
these black men if you look into that
police officers eyes they are rarely
calm they're usually freaking out
they're usually heightened beyond
imagination the video of falando
Castille has the police officer shaking
as hard as he can because he just has
this idea that falando castile is this
inhuman monster that can jump out at him
or attack him the untrained nervous
person has to be the most calm and
collected human being over the trained
Authority I think we need more social
workers I think we need more counselors
I think we need more community leaders
but I don't think we need is police
officers who are afraid of people you
can't be afraid of people when you have
to go into their communities every day
in their worst times in their most
troubling times you have to see people
and if you're afraid of that
if you
can't deal with that I don't think
police officers should be a thing then I
feel like you grow up now and you in
school you watched videos of MLK and the
marches and the civil rights movement
and everyone goes oh I totally would
have been a part of that but what they
don't realize is that is what's
happening now like this is the time this
is not something that we can drown
ourselves out with news of Brangelina
breaking up or whatever kylie jenner's
latest lip hear is like this is the
moment and this is the time and we have
to change this and no one else is going
to change this and honestly to other
white people this cannot change without
us like that's just how this works
because we are still most of the power
in this country and it has to also come
from above like it has to come from the
streets and from social media but it
also has to come from above from
positions of power from people who can
actually make a change from people who
can add policies into police enforcement
who can change whether people were body
cams who can change whether these police
officers are prosecuted when they kill
someone who has no right to be killed
every time that happens we take a
million steps back and there are people
their judges their lawyers their jurors
or people in that courtroom who could
make a difference who could say this is
unacceptable and this is a sign that
it's unacceptable but when those people
many of whom are white do not stand up
for this and do not do what's right
it just shows all the other police
officers all the other people who are
considering being violent towards other
people they're not going to be punished
and it's not something we value
ultimately it comes down to people power
if enough good people stand up in
solidarity and fight a good fight
which means bringing about justice then
we can create a community where we are
all protecting each other
I understand all the pressure that you
feel to not say anything and to support
where you work but this isn't what you
signed up for this this this isn't what
you took your oath for I would say to
the police that I love you and I respect
the sacrifice that you make every day to
put your life on the line for others but
what I am asking for you is to
understand that because of the way
things are my mother is making the same
sacrifice that your mother makes knowing
that every day you go out on the street
you have the possibility of getting
killed I'll stop being afraid of you
when you're willing to stop being afraid
of me everybody wants to get home no one
wants to die try to keep in mind if you
reverse the rules and someone pulled up
on you with the gun how are you gonna
feel let's try to make sure everybody
can get to see the next day it's not
going unheard and unwatched and unn
listen to you and it's such an awful
sacrifice do you have to sacrifice a
loved one to make people care and to
make people wake up and to make people
do better and fight for what is right
but please know that not only are your
family members names going to be heard
but this is what's gonna change it I
would say to them that I do not take
their sons sacrifice lightly I do not
your daughter sacrificed lately I do not
take your father's sacrifice lightly on
your mother's sacrifice lightly and that
I will continue to do all that I can to
make sure that people do not forget
their names I do not forget the
importance of their sacrifice we will
never understand your pain we won't but
I promise that I will live a life
charged with making change I'm sorry
that this happened to you and I'm
standing here with you because the only
way that this could haribol wrong can be
righted is if we stop it from happening
to anyone else I would think you deserve
better you deserved better your family
deserved better
I would say I love you and I care and
I'm here and it's tired and angry as I
am I will fight I will fight to honor
the lives as best as I can because it is
not your job alone to do something and
we can't do it alone
[Music]